our speculation about a so-called
revenge reshuffle of the labor
frontbencher continues this morning with
some reports saying that Hillary been
the shadow foreign secretary could be
for the job but the party is being urged
by some of its top MPs to focus on
trying to beat the Conservatives instead
while I enjoy now by the shadow
Transport Secretary Lillian Greenwood
she's in Southern in notting and shown a
very good morning to you and they're a
lot to talk about a big transport
projects but this issue within your own
party first of all jeremy corbyn's don't
even leader for about four months do you
think he needs to sort out his
frontbench well I'm very keen that we
get on with holding the government to
account rather than talking about
internal Labour Party matters and I'm
hoping that's what we're going to be
doing today talking about the staggering
rise in rail fares since David Cameron
came to office yeah yeah as I said we're
going to get straight on to that but I
just asked you if you think there is a
need more you think not then is that it
well obviously that's a matter for the
leader of the Labour Party and I don't
think it helps for for me to speculate
that Sir Jeremy all set out his thoughts
over the next over the next days and
weeks I imagine hmm i will just one
Margo editor Hilary Benn young he's
doing a good job a shadow foreign
secretary I think all my colleagues are
doing a good job and we want to be
holding the government to account over
their decisions and we've seen a number
of them doing that over the Christmas
break where we've seen the government's
failure whether it's on flooding or
whether it's on our transport policies
and I think that's what I and many of my
colleagues in the party would like to to
focus on okay so it's doing a good job
mr. been so he should stay in post well
that's a matter for Legion I'm not going
to speculate about what decisions Jeremy
wants to make but my contention is that
we need to be holding this terrible Tory
government to account and that's what
I'd like to be doing and that's what I'm
sure all my colleagues would like to be
doing right hold on to account then
about rail fares I mean in all honesty
they they didn't go as much as they have
up as much as they have done in the past
well of course it's welcome that they're
limiting rail fares film fare rises this
year but unfortunately many commuters
won't feel very satisfied by that when
they've seen their fares on average go
up by 25 percent and some commuters as a
result of ministers decisions are seeing
their rail fares rise by almost 40%
since David Cameron came to power in
2010 so a paint a picture of the
railways under labour you would
eventually nationalize all the the
operators and indeed the rail network
you therefore control fares and make
sure they don't go up at all or are cut
well we want to make sure that
passengers and taxpayers get a better
deal under this Tory government we've
seen fares rocketing we've seen delays
and problems to investment and we know
from the government's own McNulty report
that we've got our fragmented system is
up to forty percent less efficient than
the best railways in Europe so we think
was an opportunity to do better by
tackling that fragmentation by bringing
franchises back into public ownership
and that can be used to fund investment
or to limit fare rises in the future
what about hs2 I listen to your
conference speech last year and you
mentioned there yes we need the
high-speed rail and you talked about
connecting the Midlands and the north I
mean am I wrong here could I read into
that that you think pats hs2 could be
built the other way round than the
current plans well I'm a great supporter
of hs2 and it's incredibly important you
know I'm standing here in Nottingham's
you're travelling from Nottingham to
Birmingham is a very slow journey as it
is from Nottingham to Leeds those
journeys could be transformed by hs2
it's time and we want the government to
get on and get it built the whole of the
y network yet but it is that I mean
which part of the Y the prongs or the
straight bit because the current plan is
London to Birmingham first perhaps the
other bits first well obviously well I
mean we're a long way
on with the London to Birmingham part of
hs2 that legislation is well on its
route through Parliament that was the
government's decision to split it into
two I think that's regrettable we could
have got on with the whole system but we
are where we are it's important that
that part of the legislation continues
its passage through Parliament and gets
that the construction gets underway and
that we get on with phase two it's very
disappointing that the government
haven't yet confirmed the route and
station stops for Phase two and
potentially won't until the end of this
year we think they should provide some
certainty and then local authorities and
cities and people up and down the route
can get on with planning so that we
maximise the benefits of this investment
in expanding our rail network okay and
does your disappointment with the
government extend to the issue of
another runway at heathrow of course the
Davis Commission said right let's get on
with it that's a that's the one where
plumping for we were told that a
definitive decision would be taken
before Christmas of course it wasn't
would you like to see them going for
that I think it's pretty disgraceful
that the Prime Minister promised the
decision by the end of last year and
then didn't manage to deliver one reason
wasn't anywhere around to even defend
his decision it's clear there are real
issues to be tackled particularly around
how any a new runway in the southeast
could be compatible with you air quality
directive particularly if they wanted to
make that new runway at heathrow but we
knew all of that infant that when Davis
reported back in the summer and it's
shameful that the government have
actually just delayed the decision fort
seems like political reasons to avoid a
by-election in Richmond Park is that
gold to me when to step down as he's
threatened to do okay so just to be
clear labour supports right now a third
runway at heathrow
labor support a new runway in the
southeast we think that's necessary
we'll be able to take a decision purple
on government on whatever the government
proposes when we see it well we need we
need further information from the
government you just mentioned Davis
Heathrow are on the table well you must
have read the Davis condition you said
he went along with Davis and Davis says
Heathrow we welcome Davis's a report we
think that's a really helpful
contribution but there are some real
questions over the local impact both in
terms of noise and in terms of air
quality and until we see proper
proposals from the government including
more environmental information we're not
able to to make a firm decision at one
way or the other it's for the government
to bring those forward and it's very
shameful that they have booted that down
the road for clearly political reasons
when they could have got on with that
sooner that sounds a bit like
government's position to me this is one
last question that's all a couple of
cyclists go beside you there we of
course saw your leaders Christmas card
we know about his love of bikes some
this government seems to be cutting the
cycling infrastructure budget would you
restore those cuts well that we're a
long way off the next general election
and and the sort of ending commitments
we want to make but i think it is
disappointing that the government talked
about a cycling revolution and then went
on to make really large cuts to the
cycling budget in the comprehensive
spending review we want to see more
people cycling and we want to see a
long-term commitment to investment in
cycling and walking all right good to
talk to you thank you very much indeed
shadow transport secretary lily and
Greenwood there